AND THIS HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
>> INDIANA'S GOVERNOR MIKE
PENCE SURROUNDED BY NUNS,
FRANCISCAN MONKS AND
ORTHODOX JEWS SIGNED
SOMETHING CALLED THE
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
RESTORATION ACT INTO LAW.
>> SUPPORTERS SAY IT
PROTECTS A PERSON OR
BUSINESS OWNER FROM
GOVERNMENT PERSECUTION WHEN
FOLLOWING THEIR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS.
>> Jon: HERE, HERE!
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT PEOPLE
IN INDIANA COULD NOT
PRACTICE RELIGION.
I'M EXCITED.
I THOUGHT YOU COULD PRACTICE
RELIGION IN INDIANA BUT
APPARENTLY IT IS UP TO NOW
BEEN ILLEGAL,
ONE OF THOSE QUIRKY
LOCAL LAWS, I GUESS.
BUT WELL, GOD BLESS, ALL'S
WELL THAT ENDS WELL.
>> CRITICS SAY IT IS A
THINLY VEILED DISGUISE FOR
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST GAY
PEOPLE, ESSENTIALLY ALLOWING
BUSINESSES TO DENY THEM
SERVICES FOR RELIGIOUS
REASONS.
>> Jon: WHAT THE [BLEEP]?
(LAUGHTER)
WAIT, DENYING GAY PEOPLE FROM
RELIGIOUS -- GAY
PEOPLE AREN'T ASKING YOU TO
MAKE THEM A GAY PRODUCT.
THEY'RE JUST ASKING TO BUY
THE PRODUCT YOU MAKE.
ALTHOUGH PERHAPS THAT
EXPLAINS THE SIGNS IN SO
MANY INDIANA STOREFRONTS.
(LAUGHTER)
I CAN'T IMAGINE INDIANA
WOULD GET AWAY WITH THIS
TYPE OF DISCRIMINATION.
>> EVEN THE NCAA IS COMING
OUT AGAINST THE MEASURE JUST
DAYS BEFORE THE STATE'S
CAPITOL CITY HOSTS THE MEN'S
BASKETBALL CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> Jon: THAT'S GOT TO HURT.
WHEN ARE YOU BECOME
CRITICIZED BY A COMPANY
WHOSE ENTIRE BUSINESS MODEL
IS BASED ON EXPLOITATION.
YOU CAN'T DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST GAYS, YOU CAN PROFIT
ON THEIR LIKENESS WITHOUT
COMPENSATION.
(LAUGHTER)
HERE'S HOW YOU CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT.
JUST CALL THEM STUDENT GAYS.
AND BY THE WAY, IF YOU ARE
THINKING WELL WHO NEEDS THE
NCAA ANYWAY, NOT US IN
INDIANA, WELL THAT IS WHEN THE
BIG GUNS CAME OUT.
>> ANGIE'S LIST C.E.O. SAYS THE
COMPANY'S EXPANSION PROJECT
IN INDIANAPOLIS IS ON HOLD.
>> Jon: [BLEEP] JUST GOT REAL.
WITHOUT ANGIE'S LIST, HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO FIND A
TRUSTWORTHY CONTRACTOR TO
REMODEL YOUR HOUSE?
CRAIGSLIST IS NO GOOD.
THEY WILL JUST DRESS YOUR
HOUSE UP AS A FURY AND RUB
THEMSELVES ON IT. YOU
DON'T WANT THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
THAT JUST RESONATED
WAY TOO HOT.
(LAUGHTER)
THE POINT IS, THE BACKLASH
WAS SO INTENSE INDIANA
GOVERNOR MIKE PENCE HAD NO
CHOICE BUT TO RESPOND VERY
STUPIDLY.
>> DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD BE
LEGAL IN THE STATE OF
INDIANA TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST GAYS OR LESBIANS?
>> GEORGE, --
>> IT'S A YES
OR NO QUESTION.
>> LOOK COME ON, HOOSIERS DON'T
BELIEVE IN DISCRIMINATION.
THERE ARE NO KINDER, MORE
GENEROUS, MORE WELCOMING,
MORE HOSPITABLE PEOPLE IN
AMERICA THAN IN THE 92
COUNTIES OF INDIANA.
>> Jon: BUT FIRST OF ALL,
CAN WE STOP TALKING ABOUT
THE PEOPLE OF INDIANA LIKE
THEY'RE A LOST TRIBE FROM
NOSTALGIA-STAN.
THE GOOD PEOPLE OF
INDIANA, THEIR MOTTO IS
PLEASE AND THANK YOU AND THE
CURRENCY OF INDIANA IS A
HOMEMADE LEMON SQUARE.
(LAUGHTER)
LET'S FACE IT, PEOPLE IN
INDIANA ARE NO NICER OR
[BLEEP] THAN PEOPLE ANYWHERE
ELSE.
EXCEPT PHILLY, THAT'S THE
WORST.
AND D.C.
ANY -- WELL REALLY IT'S ANY NL
EAST CITY.
METS RULE!
WAIT, WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
AGAIN?
OH, INDIANA.
ANYWAY, IT SEEMS LIKE GOVERNOR
MIKE PENCE'S UNWAIVERING BELIEF
IN THE GOODNESS OF HOOSIERS DID
NEEDS SOME TWEAKING.
>> MIKE PENCE APPROVING CHANGES
TO A CONTROVERSIAL NEW LAW.
>> THE NEW LANGUAGE IN
INDIANA SPELLS OUT THE LAW DOES
NOT AUTHORIZE A PROVIDER
TO REFUSE TO OFFER OR PROVIDE
SERVICES ON THE BASIS OF SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY.
>> Jon: ANY MORE.
CAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
AND YOU CAUGHT US.
YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO
BELIEVE THAT THE CHANGE IN
LANGUAGE CAME VIA A MORAL
EPIPHANY BUT MY GUESS IS IT'S
MORE OF A AND I WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN AWAY WITH IT TOO IF IT
WEREN'T FOR YOU MEDDLING KIDS.
>> THE REASON THAT THOSE
CORPORATIONS PUT THE
PRESSURE ON INDIANA AND
ARKANSAS WAS BECAUSE THE
MILITANT GAY COMMUNITY PUT THE
PRESSURE ON THEM.
>> Jon: SHUT UP.
SO WHEN GAYS WANT EQUALITY
IT'S MILITANCY.
AND WHEN CHRISTIANS WANT TO
DENY SERVICE, IT'S FREEDOM.
SEE THOSE WHO ARE DEFENDING
THIS SORT OF LAW, GO VERY
FAR OUT OF THEIR WAY TO SAY
HOW IT'S NOT DISCRIMINATORY
TOWARDS ANYBODY, ESPECIALLY
GAY PEOPLE.
THEY'VE GOT NOTHING AGAINST
AND THEY USE ANALOGIES TO
CLARIFY THEIR POSITION.
WHICH ANALOGIES DO, JUST NOT
IN THE WAY THEY INTENDED.
>> IF YOU ARE A PRINT SHOP
AND YOU ARE A GAY MAN,
SHOULD YOU BE FORCED TO
PRINT GOD HATES FAGS FOR THE
WESTBOROUGH BAPTIST CHURCH?
>> IF A KKK MEMBER COMES IN AND
SAYS I WANT A BIRTHDAY CAKE
MADE TO CELEBRATE THE BIRTH
OF THE KKK, SHOULD A BAKER
REGARDLESS OF THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN, BE ABLE TO SAY,
I AM NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT
CAKE.
>> I WOULD THINK I WOULD
GIVE THE SAME RIGHT TO A
JEWISH BAKER TO NOT HAVE TO
PUT A SWASTIKA ON A BILL.
>> Jon: IT'S BEEN AWHILE
SINCE I'VE TAKEN THE SATs.
BUT I BELIEVE THE
FORMULATION AS YOU DEFEND
YOURSELVES IS THIS.
THIS COUPLE IS TO CHRISTIAN
BUSINESS AS THESE FOLKS ARE
TO EVERYONE ELSE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
I'M NOT DISCRIMINATING, I
HAVE NOTHING AGAINST GAY
PEOPLE, I'M JUST SAYING, FOR
SOME CHRISTIANS, CATERING AN
ELDERLY LESBIAN WEDDING IS
LIKE MAKING A JEW SLOW DANCE
WITH HITLER.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
(LAUGHTER)
DO YOU SEE HOW [BLEEP] THAT IS?
BASICALLY YOU SEE PEOPLE
CELEBRATING LOVE AS A HATE
GROUP.
ALTHOUGH, THERE IS GOOD
NEWS.
>> IT REMAINS LEGAL IN MOST
OF INDIANA TO FIRE SOMEONE
BECAUSE THEY'RE GAY.
>> Jon: YES!
SO THE LESSON HERE IS
CLEAR.
YOU ARE IN INDIANA AND YOU
GET FIRED FOR BEING GAY,
MAKE THOSE MOTHER [BLEEP]
CATER YOUR WEDDING.